this is from fresh and fit i think this
is myron i'm talking about good looks
this isn't all controversial some of it
is just an important message i think i
like this one from myron i think he's
right
let's play it
for dating absolutely but here's the
thing if you're a good-looking guy but
you don't know how to speak you have no
social calibration and you're weird
she's going to quickly get turned off by
you good looks all it does guys is it
allows you an entryway
right to communicate so that you can
spit your game but if you come off weird
or awkward she's probably gonna walk
away from you unless you got some kind
of status or some kind of other
amplifier that makes up for your lack of
social calibration but good looks are
definitely important and help you get
your foot in the door but to keep the
door open you need the game this is i
think a really important message that
he's sending here and i think it's
important for good looking guys in
particular because they get lazy they
get really really lazy sometimes um and
i remember
i remember i was like 22 23 and i met
this guy
i was waitressing at the time i had
already had my graduate degree i got my
graduate degree very young i came out
with a masters i was 22 years old
valedictorian masters degree i came out
and i was like i'm exhausted that's
honestly how it happened i was
completely exhausted i said i need a
minute
i need a minute i remember i was
waitress saying i was you know having a
good time was like for the first time i
could breathe i had gone through four
years of high school four years of
college school school school school and
i like got a chance to just
and i was like i'm taking it and i met
this guy he was
universally good-looking i mean he was
doing modeling he was fit he was just
really like caught the eye of and he
would catch the eye even if it wasn't
your type you know everybody's got their
type
um you you would be like he's just
good look in fact my best friend at the
time was like he's not my type but he's
a good looking guy
poor guy couldn't hold conversation so
you could literally make it happen you
could make it work if you were the type
person that was like just shh you know
and it was just you just looked at him
and you just kind of it would have to be
that though he had never had to really
work in anything else he wasn't funny
he couldn't hold a conversation
he he was just
socially very awkward
um not not terribly oddly not terribly
confident and i wonder if that was
because he knew that beyond the looks
like
there was some type of vacancy going on
so this is an important message it
doesn't first of all good looking
it's not just about like being
universally good looking everyone's got
their thing sometimes it's about just
having a certain what is it je ne sais
quoi you got something going on you got
some sort of fire right
also good looking comes with like how
you carry yourself as a guy i think it's
super important the way you carry
yourself the way you walk into a room
what's super attractive oftentimes about
men is men who don't give a [ __ ]
about how you feel about them
initially right like they're not worried
about like oh i need to dress like this
that a woman's gonna like it or i need
to do this so they're just them they're
very comfortable in their own skins
they're wearing what they're wearing
their hair looks the way it looks maybe
their sandals are a little busted up
whatever it is they're totally cool with
who they are they've got a presence when
they walk in that's just like hey
take it or leave it you know that's very
very attractive
but you know important message because i
do notice and you know you always hear
that um
cliche about good-looking guys that that
they're terrible in bed you hear it you
hear it i don't really know if that's
true that i don't think that's been my
experience really not somebody's been
around blocked that much but regardless
good looking guys they always say they
don't have to work at anything because
girls want to be with them because
they're good looking so they get the
girl into bed and they never had to
figure out how to work the machinery
so
they don't know how and they're just
like oh what's going on here and they
just kind of like
get through it um as opposed to guys
that maybe didn't have it so easy and
weren't as good-looking but they had to
you know figure out maybe they became
really funny and they became really
charming and they were like i'm gonna
figure out a woman's body because i'm
gonna make her really happy to you know
be with me and they just worked a little
harder so if you're good looking don't
see it as a pass just saying there's a
lot more to the package that is
interesting than just what you look like
that's going to be like boring after
like five seconds if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]